hey everybody and welcome to the latest
episode of the Shawn method I'm Shawn
McGinnis and this is Rob handler e
filling in for Chris waters whoo that's
right still in Boston four packs he
decided he just never wanted to leave I
think oh good for them yeah good for him
you know he went there he fell in love
with it and now he's just never coming
home
or maybe he's visiting relatives it's
yeah those two it's a couple yeah its
I'm not sure exactly at any rate
whatever who cares man I'll do my best
so you remember last week we played
hitman blood money and today we're gonna
keep the hitman train rolling with
hitman absolution a game that has its
flaws yeah you know a lot of hitman
purists didn't really care for this game
a whole lot but it's still fun sandbox a
game if you're into goofing around which
we are doing which we are doing yes are
you worried about that so what we're
gonna do we're gonna skip the main story
stuff and we're just checking out the
contracts right now because it's just a
little bit more freeform a little more
chaotic contracts are basically like
other players have created their own
missions looks like this guy created a
mission that is pretty much identical to
the main story missions so not the most
imaginative guy in the world but God
bless his heart anyways good I would
hate to be killed by every single one of
these people yes we robe its Rome turns
out the answer to that question was robe
it was robe the whole time we just
didn't know it yet until we got to it
you touched my car yeah go check out
your car buddy it's gonna be totally
safe and fine Oh where'd that dead body
come from oh oh jeez Oh
oh he's dead he's dead good you know
what I didn't actually mean to do this
first mission so cleanly I was gonna
goof around a little bit more and then
I'm working out pretty well that's fine
well compete complete this one and then
replay it and show you just approach
different way different way a different
way of plans mission alright we're gonna
create a distraction and then pin you
out one of our targets ready set go aha
now's the time that's a time uh it's X
and running boys still convinced this
the new 1-800 all right quick quick now
still we still got a window opportunity
we just gotta be quick about it where is
he where is he here you are
oh yes oh here he is
oh he's looking for you oh hi there
oh you don't want to go in there there's
a dead body in there you want no part of
that
hey you my friend you wear the same
clothes Hey
you look just like this guy I know he
lives here he's not bald though he
doesn't have a tattoo on the back of his
neck but you look just like him you two
would like each other you two would like
each other
you've got similar fashion sensibilities
oh yeah just walk in there don't just do
me a favor don't walk to the dead body
okay all right no need to be suspicious
there's just a my god no put this here
did I do this I didn't oh no I feel a
little guilty now oh this one look like
someone peeled his face back I feel
guilty I would feel pretty bad I feel
bad now that's on me guys he's gonna
have a hangover tomorrow guys that one's
on me did I did I think it kind of did
that explosion yeah it was already there
like I had to have been there yes yes
we've been pretty sure he's sleeping on
his easy mark and this person is pissed
if I found the body which body did they
find though there's like
any of them I'm gonna go to the strip
club that one's pretty fun that's cool
place the fixing club search for
contracts why are all these targets
strippers that's very weird don't like
Elster feel like it if I'm gonna get
their attention
I gotta get up here excuse me gentlemen
ladies you can go home there's a new
priest in town there's a new Prince in
town and he knows how to dance
yeah get out of my get listen you're in
my way people are enough it's my pole
drama on the runway yeah you boys like
this I called myself priest Oh people
are not happy with this I call myself
father 47 like what you see you can
stuff a dollar anywhere you want
I got no limits so father I've been a
naughty boy I'll just I'll take this I'm
sorry I get your point
yeah you're mad you're mad and who can
blame you who can blame you I'm just
going to leave this strip club what guys
could you get that for in thanks my work
here is done
you found yourself a nun I'm just gonna
take her back take her back to my place
do you think these guys are the front
are gonna be angry when they see me
dragging this gentleman don't mind me
I'm just returning back to my covenant
it's fine oh no it's okay everyone chill
out guys guys guys
I'm gonna use my instinct you don't
never know I was here
gentlemen I will see you later
I had a great time really great time
whoa hello please in here what are you
doing with shant okay Oh perfect and
contract Oh what I forgot to execute my
target you stay here all the single
ladies all the single men
oh he said he's trying to imitate you
he's learning it's fine you don't want
to do it it's fine just go sleep we'll
try it again tomorrow dancing your
dreams and the perfect crime is hey that
was our best dancer Oh why'd you go and
get rid of her my name's Jenny [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm here for this giant birthday party
that's happening on Chinese New Year
Happy New Year Happy New Year kids
my name is chippy I'm gonna come back
for you later looks like I got my target
I got my target he's right here chippy
smoked a lot of cigarettes teen years he
did he's uh he's come a long way he's
made some bad life decisions let's just
say emphysema Happy New Year Happy New
Year everybody here's a little gift from
your friend chippy and now I gotta go
cuz it's getting real hot leave no this
is a relief oh [ __ ]
that's okay I have a backup option
excuse me back turns out jelly went
through the wrong door Charlie's gonna
take out this one stripper totally let's
be honest is a real piece of [ __ ] it's a
little bit of a misogynist which is one
of many many deep personal flaws of his
he means well but he's just a real piece
of [ __ ] Charlie's got some personal
troubles don't judge him typical Tuesday
typical Tuesday at the office you guys
go check out that dead that grab a
bottle over there Charlie's just gonna
climb out this ledge this isn't creepy
at all look at his wide stance it's good
he's so good yeah get a view of this
please hey what's your stance on NEFT
procon you tell me I got whatever don't
have to be meth what how would you feel
if I just stood behind you like
it was like Miko from GTA halos what if
I just breathe down your neck
are you uncomfortable tell me if I smell
like acorns and walnuts hey em you guys
see a chipmunk yeah if you guys see a
chipmunk you get me watch watch yeah
that guy's a real wild card oh well look
who's on stage just gonna hide here
nobody's gonna find me up this way she's
running oh no where you going
that's for Charlie yeah I think so yeah
yeah back in my natural this guy's yeah
Jolly's come in come chuckles Charlie
I'm just gonna climb back out the
Charlie hole sure excuse me gotta take
care of some business
oh I smell yeah I feel really bad about
this you should know that Charlie's done
here Charlie's gonna just yeah it's just
sneaking through him stay in his
contract Charlie's got eighty seven
thousand bones in the bank now Wow that
episode got real weird real fast it did
it got real weird but you know what I
think we learned a thing or two about
Charlie the chipmunk definitely like he
liked speed you love speed he likes meth
he likes anything where he can get
flashbacks of Vietnam yeah
he's painting a home flashbacks and he
didn't even fight there he just went
there on vacation had a really bad time
look at that time so yeah that was a
maybe the weirdest episode of the show
method yet I hope you guys enjoyed it
Rob thanks for co-host oh thank you for
having me that's a good time lots of fun
make sure to come back next week at
11:00 a.m. Pacific time for even more
chaos and insanity and if you guys want
to suggest a game to play on the show
hit me up on twitter at s McInnis and
we'll see you next week